hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the beginning
of metaphysics book 1 Aristotle writes
one of his most famous statements that
is all human beings by nature desire to
know or knowledge and there's a lot of
different ways in which we can talk
about knowing and knowledge a lot of
different Arts and Sciences
there's also experience but one of them
is particularly important for Aristotle
he is a philosopher and he's also going
to tell us about the origin of
philosophy which according to him lies
in trying to develop trying to attain
knowledge motivated by something in
particular an experience and here's
where we get another one of his
extremely famous lines he says
philosophy begins in wandering or in
wonder or aw you could translate this in
a number of different ways how Maude's
Ain the verb is the Greek term that's
being used there and it means another
way of translating it to Marvel so we do
desire knowledge and some things within
the
world draw us in further now Aristotle
thinks that this this working of human
beings because of their very nature and
their capabilities doesn't lead us to
philosophy right at the very beginning
so he wouldn't say that you know early
human beings are all philosophers or
children by their very you know origin
are automatically philosophers or
anything of that sort because for him
philosophy is a bit more advanced you
could say of an inquiry he does tell us
early on about the development of the
arts and the sciences the techn I and
the epistle
in Greek and he tells us that first we
human beings after we get beyond the
realm of mere memory and experience and
we actually start to figure out how
things work we start to develop bodies
of knowledge or disciplines we do so
motivated first by practical concerns so
we develop those as he says that are
useful for life for our living for
preserving life for living better some
of these deal with things that he calls
necessities time an kaya the things that
we are bound to deal with so you know if
we are say herders we start to figure
out something about how to take herd
animals and get them safely from point A
to point B with losing as few of them as
possible or we start to figure out what
to do with their hides or their wool and
we develop these techniques that
eventually we can have some actual
knowledge about and teach to other
people
some of them deal with what we can
translate as pastimes or he also says at
another point with pleasure so quite a
few of the arts and sciences that we
develop after we get past the realm of
mere necessity have to do with making
our life more enjoyable
so think about Agra
culture for example it's really useful
to know how irrigation works and about
you know weeding and maneuvering and all
these other things that we can you know
talk about as part of the body of
knowledge of Agriculture and then we
could start to breed things to make them
more tasty melons you know were popular
in the ancient world cucumbers were
another thing as well that he could
could have referred to because they were
bred very early but he's not
particularly interested in that neither
are we
well we're really interested in is other
kinds of studies studies that are not
being carried out for their practical
effects although they could have some
practical utility but are being carried
out by a pure desire for knowledge
knowledge for the sake of knowing
theoretical as he's going to call it
knowledge as opposed to practical
leisure is what makes this possible so
he talks for example about the Egyptians
and developing the rudiments of
mathematics because they had a class of
the priests who were actually leisured
and able to start studying this for its
own sake not just for the sake of
dividing up land equally but to think
about numbers and so we we then have
studies that we carry out for the sake
of knowing we start doing them because
we value knowledge for its own sake not
just because it'll help us plow the
fields better or create more grain or
have you know straighter lines or
anything like that but because we want
to know now here's where we get into the
the famous line about philosophy having
its origin in wonder or in amazement or
marveling he tells us that through
wonder dia told thum thum insane people
begin to any use of the word
philosophize they begin to have a love
of wisdom a desire for wisdom they carry
out the activity
trying to attain wisdom it's not all
simply the experience of so oh my gosh
this is so amazing that sort of thing
it's also being as we could say
perplexed or finding ourselves unable to
provide an account unable to explain
something and so he also uses in the
verbal and also the noun form this term
upper area and this is a word that the
ancient Greeks use it literally means
being hemmed in you you go into
something and there's no way out there's
no path to get out of there you could go
backwards but then you're not achieving
anything so you're kind of stuck and we
have this experience many times when we
are wandering when we are marveling we
say how does that happen
what what's going on there and we're not
able to provide ourselves with an answer
that satisfies so that motivates us this
healing this effective experience which
is also cognitive because we feel
ourselves as he says to be ignorant
literally the verb to not know to not
have knowledge of something and that
leads us then to desire and to pursue
knowledge to try to get ourselves out of
the state of ignorance and into a state
of knowing something to be the case of
understanding it and this is something
that we not only think to ourselves we
desire it we pursue it this is how we
orient ourselves practically he gives us
some interesting examples about what
this might encompass before that though
he also tells us very importantly that
we wonder not only about these things
but we wonder or we're in awe or were
marveling at the fact that things are as
they are in the way that they are in
Greek who toasts okay that they they
hold themselves or are conditioned or
are structured or appear in a certain
manner to us and this is going beyond
just the sheer fact isset e of things
are the way they are we want to
understand how they are and we also want
to understand a much more important
question that's at the very core of
metaphysics why are things the way they
are what's going on there with each of
these examples now he gives us some
great examples one of which I'm going to
come back to a little bit later I'm
gonna skip over the first one for the
moment one of these is changes as he
says or motions of the Sun and the moon
and the stars the the things that we can
observe above and you know what would
this include you know the solstices he
has an example there probably you would
also say eclipses are things that we're
interested in the regular patterns that
we observe with heavenly bodies all of
those sorts of things are matters about
which we can wonder and he says that you
know mythmakers are actually in a
certain way beginning to do philosophy
because they introduce all sorts of
wonders for us and think about what some
of the myths in nearly every culture
have to do with the astral or heavenly
bodies we want to know what's going on
with these why are they behaving the way
that they do what is the Sun is it a
ball of fire is a kind of rock what
what's going on with that that's the
sort of thing that gets us to start
doing philosophy he also talks about a
mathematical example the
incommensurability
of the diagonal of the square now what
does that mean well you don't think
about a square the diagonal is the line
running through it talking about the
incommensurability means that you
can't find a ratio between the sides
that actually translates into to that
particular number there it was it was a
problem that we don't really have in
modern modern mathematics or geometry
because we understand how squares work
and how to work with them but for the
ancients this was very perplexing this
was a problem set for them that they
wanted to make some sense of and he says
something really interesting about that
particular example he says that it seems
wonderful or amazing to everyone who has
not yet perceived the cause that a thing
should not be measurable by the smallest
unit that's what the incommensurability
means but he says for a geometry
actually does understand it it would it
would be incredible it would be
something to wonder at if the diagonal
were suddenly to become measurable they
would want to know how did this happen
right now another thing that he talks
about about which scholars don't always
agree on the exact translation or
reference is the automata and you'll see
this often translated in the metaphysics
as marionettes what a lot of scholars
think these are would be in effect toys
or models perhaps of heavenly phenomena
perhaps of you know animals or or other
things that moved on their own so think
not quite so advanced but think of like
windup toys think of a mouse for example
where you wind it up and because of the
the spring action it makes wheels roll
and a cat chases if the cat thinks that
it's a self moving thing a mouse they
weren't quite so advanced as that in
terms of you know that type of
technology but they certainly did have
things like that in Aristotle's time and
so that's probably what he's referring
to here we don't really know exactly
what this
hurm signifies but that's a good guess
and if you were an ordinary person
seeing for example some mechanical toy
or seeing some sort of model of the
universe with with spheres that rotate
you might say whoa what is this thing
what what's going on here and then you
would start to think about it you would
want to move from a state of wonder and
perplexity to a state of knowledge and
philosophy would do that for you the
last example I want to talk about is one
that's no longer just you could say in
the physical world but has incredible
metaphysical import Aristotle says that
one of the other things that we wonder
about that leads us into studying
philosophy is the origins of everything
and he he is using those those exact
terms there you know it's a the pond
tastes every single thing and here we go
kai pantry tastes hoop on toast Ganesh
AOS Canaan tales is the genitive of
Genesis the word we translate in English
as Genesis or origin so the beginnings
or the origins or the coming to be of
everything that is a philosophical
question as well that can provoke wonder
why is everything the way it is how did
all of this come to be
so this is where philosophy begins
according to Aristotle in metaphysics
book 1
you